If our index document
is served over HTTPS, great.
But what about
the site's assets?
Are they surfed
over HTTPS as well?
A fast way to break that
beautiful green lock is
having your assets
surfed over regular HTTP.
When this happens,
the site ends up
in a state called mixed content.
Mixed content
occurs when you open
a website that is supposed
to be delivered over HTTPS,
but includes resources
like images, I-frame,
style sheets, or scripts,
from non-TLS secured origins.
A popular mistake
is pulling in jQuery
from a non-TLS enabled CDN.
Depending on the type of
research that is being included
over a non-secure channel,
the consequences might differ.
It might cost you
your green padlock,
but still remain functional.
The resource might get
blocked or break your page,
or it might even get the
horrible red padlock of shame.
The behavior differs
across different browsers
so you should definitely
avoid it and check
a website for mixed content.
In fact, Google recommends
that you surf all your assets
over HTTPS.
This way you'll avoid mixed
content warnings and your site
and its assets will be
transferred securely.